TO THE KKK.
HERE TO TALK ABOUT THIS AND
MORE RNC NATIONAL
SPOKESWOMAN KAYLEIGH MCENANY
AND ARIZONA CONGRESSMAN AND
HOUSE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
MEMBER ANDY BIGGS.
I WILL START WITH YOU, LET'S
TALK ABOUT THIS BACK AND
FORTH BETWEEN THE PRESIDENT
AND CHIEF JUSTICE JOHN
ROBERTS.
THE PRESIDENT, OF COURSE,
CONTINUED TODAY TALKING
ABOUT THE FACT THAT, YOU
KNOW, JUDGES ARE NOT
NECESSARILY ALL STRAIGHT
SHOOTERS.
ARE JUDGES PARTISAN?
>> WELL, JUDGE, YOU KNOW, I
HAVE TRIED A FEW CASES IN MY
TIME, AND I CAN TELL YOU
THAT YES, ON POLITICAL
ISSUES I THINK SOME OF THEM
MIGHT HAVE A LITTLE BIAS.
YOU CAN'T TELL ME THAT.
SO JUDGES IN THE FEDERAL
DISTRICT COURT DON'T HAVE AN
ANIMUS AGAINST DONALD J.
TRUMP AND WISHED THAT
HILLARY CLINTON WAS STILL
THERE.
YOU JUST CAN'T -- NOBODY
BELIEVES THAT THAT STRETCHES
CREDIT JIEWTTLE AND MAYBE
JUSTICE ROBERTS IS
PROJECTING HIS OWN NAIVETE
AGAINST BIAS QUITE FRANKLY.
YOU KNOW WITH THAT RECENT
RULING IT WAS LOWER COURT
ISSUING ONCE AGAIN A
NATIONAL INJUNCTION AGAINST
THIS ADMINISTRATION.
AND THAT'S REALLY
PROBLEMATIC.
WE HAVE GOT TO STOP THOSE
NATIONAL INJUNCTIONS.
>> Judge Jeanine: YOU KNOW,
CONGRESSMAN,I WILL GET TO
THE BILL THAT YOU ARE
SPONSORING.
THE BILLS THAT YOU ARE
I WANT TO GO TO KAYLEIGH
MCENANY.
KAYLEIGH, THE TRUTH IS THAT
WHAT WE HAVE GOT WE HAVE GOT
FORUM SHOPPING ON SOME OF
THE BIGGEST ISSUES THAT
INVOLVE OUR COUNTRY AND IN
THE LAST SEGMENT WE TALKED
ABOUT THE FACT THAT
IMMIGRATION IS NOW FOR MANY
PEOPLE THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE.
HOW IS IT THAT THEY KEEP
GOING TO THE 9TH CIRCUIT OR
COURTS WHERE, YOU KNOW, IT
WILL MOVE UP TO THE 9TH
CIRCUIT AND THEN SOME LOCAL,
I'M CALLING HIM A LOCAL
DISTRICT JUDGE GETS TO DO A
TEMPORARY RESTRAINING ORDER
THAT ENJOINS THE WHOLE
COUNTRY?
HOW DOES THAT WORK?
>> THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
YEAH.
YOU HAVE PARTISAN HACKS OUT
THERE FINDING THE MOST
LIBERAL JUDGE THEY CAN FIND
TO THEN LEVEL A DECISION
THAT REBUKES THE POWER OF
THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
THE PRESIDENT HAS THAT POWER
OVER IMMIGRATION.
THAT WAS DECIDED IN TRUMP
VS. HAWAII WHEN THE SUPREME
COURT LITERALLY SAID HE HAS
THE POWER TO DO THIS.
IT WAS AFTER A JUDGE IN
HAWAII UNILATERALLY STRUCK
DOWN THE TEMPORARY TRAVEL
BAN.
THE SUPREME COURT, OF
COURSE, UPHELD THAT NOW HAVE
YOU ANOTHER LIBERAL ACTIVIST
JUDGE DOING THE SAME THING
WITH THIS ASYLUM EXECUTIVE
ORDER.
IT'S FORUM SHOPPING.
IT'S ACTIVIST JUDGES AND
JUDICIARY WIELDING POWER
THEY DO NOT HAVE TO REBUKE
THE LEGITIMATE MAYOR
THE LEGITIMATE MAUOR
THE LEGITIMATE MAURY POWER
OF THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH AS
LAID OUT IN THE UNITED
STATES.
>> Judge Jeanine: WITH THE
SUPREME COURT JUDGE GETTING
INVOLVED IT'S ALMOST A TACET
APPROVAL OF THE DISTRICT
JUDGES SAY I WILL ENJOIN THE
COUNTRY.
ANYWAY, PRESIDENT TRUMP
YESTERDAY CONTINUED HIS
ATTACK ON THE FAR LEFT NINTH
CIRCUIT OF APPEALS.
LOOK AT THIS.
>> WE ARE GETTING SOME
TERRIBLE DECISIONS FROM THE
NINTH CIRCUIT AS USUAL.
AND IT'S A SHAME.
IT'S A SHAME.
IT'S A DISGRACE, FRANKLY.
ESSENTIALLY THEY ARE
LEGISLATING.
THEY ARE SAYING WHAT TO DO.
SOME JUDGE SITTING IN SOME
LOCATION VERY FAR AWAY IS
TELLING OUR INCREDIBLE
MILITARY AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
WHAT TO DO AND IT'S NOT
RIGHT.
HOPEFULLY WE HAVE SHOWN SOME
LIGHT ON THE NINTH CIRCUIT.
I KNOW THAT CHIEF JUSTICE
ROBERTS, JOHN ROBERTS HAS
BEEN SPEAKING A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT IT.
>> Judge: I GOT TO TELL YOU,
CONGRESSMAN, WHEN I WAS A
JUDGE, WE NEVER EVER GOT
INVOLVED IN ANY WAY, SHAPE,
OR FORM.
AND I SAID THIS THE OTHER
NIGHT WHEN I HOSTED HANNITY
THAT IT IS SO, TO ME,
STUNNING THAT A SUPREME
COURT JUSTICE WOULD COME OUT
AND PUSH BACK AT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
YOU KNOW, THE PRESIDENT IS
POLITICAL.
THE SUPREME COURT JUSTICE IS
NOT, ESPECIALLY THE CHIEF
JUSTICE.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE NINTH
CIRCUIT AND WHAT WE HAVE GOT
AND HOW THIS CIRCUIT IS, YOU
KNOW, CONSIDERED ALMOST A
CIRCUS GIVEN THEIR
DECISIONS.
>> RIGHT.
WELL, WE CALL IT THE 9TH
CIRCUS HIS OR HER IT
STRETCHES FROM ALASKA TO
ALMOST THE EQUATE
ALMOST THE EEQATE
ALMOST THE EEQUAE
ALMOST THE EEQUATER.
WE CAN'T EVEN GET EN BANC
HEARING.
WE ARE STACKED UP AND CAN'T
EVEN GET EN BANC HEARING AND
QUITE FRANKLY ARIZONA AND
THE INNER MOUNTAIN WEST, WE
ARE NOT REALLY COPASETIC
WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MENTALITY AND COASTAL
MENTALITY.
I HAVE A BILL TO SPLIT UP
THE NINTH CIRCUIT.
WE CAN'T SEEM TO GET ANY
ANGST ON IT WE HAVE
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTATIVES
BECAUSE THEY WANT THEIR
PORTION OF CALIFORNIA OUT OF
THE 9TH CIRCUIT AND INTO THE
12TH CIRCUIT.
THAT'S REALLY WHAT'S GOING
ON.
>> Judge Jeanine: KAYLEIGH
WHAT THE CONGRESSMAN IS
PROPOSE SOMETHING PLIGHT UP
9TH CIRCUIT NOW 29 JUSTICES.
THE LARGEST IN THE COUNTRY.
WHAT HE WAS REFERRING TO IS
THE FACT IN HIS BILL THAT
THE 9TH CIRCUIT DOESN'T
REFLECT THE VALUES OF THE
STATE THAT HE IS FROM.
SO HE WANTS TO GET OUT OF
IT.
AND, I MEAN, IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE SEEN
DONE IN THE PAST?
>> THE CONGRESSMAN IS SPOT
ON.
I THINK THIS IS A GREAT
PROPOSAL.
IT MAKES A LOT OF SENSE.
THE 9TH CIRCUIT DOESN'T JUST
REPRESENT THE AREA OVER
WHICH THEY RULE, THEY DON'T
REPRESENT THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA.
THEY'RE THE MOST OVERTURNED
CIRCUIT FOR A REASON.
[LAUGHTER]
IT'S A FACT.
AND LOOK AT BY THE WAY I
HAVE GOT TO SAY WITH JUSTICE
ROBERTS THERE, WHERE WAS HE
BEING VOCAL WHEN RUTH BADER
GINSBURG CAME OUT AGAINST
THE PRESIDENT AND MADE
PARTISAN COMMENTS NO JUSTICE
HAS MADE LIKE THAT IN THE
PAST.
>> Judge Jeanine: BARACK
OBAMA WHEN AFTER THE WHOLE
SUPREME COURT WHEN HE WAS
GIVING HIS STATE OF THE
UNION BUT CONGRESSMAN, ONE
MORE THING TO YOU ONE OF THE
ARGUMENTS IT WOULD SEEM TO
ME ON BEHALF TO SPLIT THAT
CIRCUIT IS THAT THERE HAS
GOT TO BE DELAYS.
THAT CIRCUIT HAS TO HAVE A
LOT OF CASES GIVEN THE HUGE
NUMBER OF STATES.
YOU KNOW, IT'S LIKE -- IT'S
CALIFORNIA, IT'S MONTANA.
IT'S THE STATE OF
WASHINGTON.
GIVE ME ALL OF THEM.
IT'S ARIZONA.
>> YOU CAN'T EVEN -- WHO CAN
NAME THEM ALL BECAUSE WE ARE
TALKING TERRITORIES THAT
STRETCH DOWN TO THE EQUATE EQUAT
STRETCH DOWN TO THE EQUATE EQUAR
STRETCH DOWN TO THE EQUATE EQUA.
>> IF YOU ARE LIVING IN
MONTANA AND EAST SIDE OF
MONTANA AND HAVE TO GO TO
SAN FRANCISCO TO HAVE YOUR
CASE HEARD, THAT'S
PROBLEMATIC.
AND SO THEY SAY WELL, WE CAN
SKYPE IT OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT.